So, when I was 15, I remember going to my mom and sort of telling her, like, I'm having
a hard time, like, seeing what's in front of me, I'm having a hard time seeing the board.
I didn't think much of it, you know, because I didn't really just didn't think much of
it.
But I realized that I'm sitting in the back of class and where I like to sit.
I couldn't see anything.
And then it really got sort of serious when I started to drive and I realized
that some signs that I think I might be, should be able to see or my friends
have told me about that I'm not seeing, something's not right.
And so, you know, I went to the doctors, went to the eye doctor, and they did all the little
checks.
They put the little thing on your face and they, you know, do all the dialing and you
read the lines and the letters and all that kind of stuff, and they didn't think much
of it.
And they told me, you know, flip the lenses and which one is better and did the
whole process of getting fitted for a pair of glasses.
And I thought nothing of it.
Until I walked in the day and picked them up.
And I picked them up and I looked at them and for the first time I put glasses on and
all of a sudden the world completely changed.
Things were sharper.
I could see things that I didn't even know existed from across the room.
My entire perception, my entire reality really started to change because now I could actually
see the way I was supposed to see.
We're talking about world views.
The most simplistic way to sort of see it and understand it is simply this.
Is by looking at the world through a set of lenses.
And how you look through those lenses sort of dictates how you see the world.
World view, how I view the world, right?
So, but more than that, world views and what you should start to now see through
the world view questions that were introduced.
But world views are foundational.
They are life-shaping questions about reality.
So it's not just the pair of glasses that I'm looking at through to see the world.
It's literally how I'm interpreting it and how I'm living as a result of that view.
So all those students should see very quickly through some of the activities in the Bible
study that a biblical world view has a profound impact on how we live.
So this week I want you to keep three really important things in mind as you work through
this lesson.
Now we've talked about things like what apologetics is and we've talked about what faith is.
We've talked about what truth is.
We've talked about logic.
We've laid this foundation so that you can continue to move through this study.
But now we need students to really understand what it means to see the world through a
particular lens.
But we don't just want them to see the world through the Christian lens.
We want them to understand the world through a couple other popular ways of seeing, naturalism
and pantheism.
Then we're going to talk about what it looks like from a monotheistic world view.
Because the way in which other people see the world is going to vastly, widely influence
how your students start to see the world.
So when people who see the world differently are involved in making movies and writing music
and doing art and making TV shows and whatever else it is and writing and books and everything
else, that world view is going to get communicated to your students.
So they need to start to be able to see that.
But before we can start into all of that, there's three really important things I
want you to keep in mind because there's some things that are going to come up here
that are going to be pretty impactful.
Number one, don't assume your students have a biblical world view.
Now, if your group has what most are going to call themselves Christians, I say your
group is a typical youth group that has the majority of Christians.
You might automatically just sort of assume that, hey, my students have a Christian
world view or a biblical world view that may not necessarily be the case.
You're going to discover that your students have some inconsistencies and some contradictions
in their world view.
In fact, world views are often, if you can imagine, going to a buffet restaurant.
World views are often like that now.
I mean, think about all the information that we have, think about all the, what's
available to our students via the internet, that as soon as they want to know something,
what do we ask?
We ask Google, we ask Siri, we ask the questions over the internet to figure
out the answers to our questions rather than asking, you know, we're going to a library
and looking at a book and considering the source.
We just ask and we look at the top five views on Google and we go with it.
Our students have more information available to them than any other time in history.
So what happens is students have what I call a buffet world view.
You walk into a restaurant that's got a buffet and grab a plate and you just
start taking food that looks good and you just start grabbing whatever that you
want and then when you're done with that, you get rid of that plate, you go back to
the buffet and you grab different stuff that looked good the next time or maybe
you go back and grab some seconds of stuff that you really liked but you
grab it all together and you just eat at a very low discounted price, right?
So you may just automatically think that they have a biblical world view because
somewhere along that buffet, there are pieces of Christianity, pieces of
Scripture in their world view but then as you explore deeper, especially your
small group leaders, as they explore deeper and get more into conversations and
build deeper relationships with those students, they're going to discover that
there's some significant inconsistencies.
Now, don't panic, that's okay because as we move through this process, we'll
hopefully iron out those inconsistencies and help them and guide them
through a more consistent world view.
That's what the actual world view questions are designed to do, right?
By asking those four questions, it draws out what they think but it also reveals
the flaws in thinking in a nice, gentle, respectful way.
So make sure, encourage and hopefully you've created this environment
already but encourage your students to answer honestly.
We don't want the answers that they think we want to hear, we want their
actual answers, whatever they may be.
So don't freak out if you hear something that just totally you did not expect.
Number two, world views have to be coherent and consistent.
Even though the buffet sounds really good and it works for some, at least it
seems like it works for some, it doesn't and over time that will cause problems.
That's why you go back for seconds and you take different things because
it's the search for trying to figure out the best possible combination that
doesn't work.
So you're going to, you know, throughout this process we're going to be helping
students understand that this is what makes Christianity so compelling
is that it's entirely coherent and it's entirely consistent.
And finally, don't expect students to change their world view right away.
Just because you see that they have a different world view or they have
inconsistencies in their world view or there's some questions in their world view
and you present, even at the end of this 32 weeks, if you present, you know,
you're presenting the Christian world view, don't expect them that they're just
going to go, oh, I'm going to put on a whole new pair of glasses and I'm going to
see the world totally different.
It doesn't work that way.
In fact, it doesn't work that way at all.
In fact, changing how we see the world is not as easy as just changing a
prescription on a pair of glasses.
It's a huge, huge adjustment.
In fact, sometimes so big that it causes discomfort, it causes anxiety
because people to change how you see the world is to really change almost your
entire reality of how you understand things and how you answer big questions
in life and how you interact with people.
That's a lot of change.
So be patient with your students.
Walk alongside them.
Help them figure it all out.
All right, so over the last several weeks, we've challenged you with a lot of
adjustments that you kind of need to make within the context of your group.
We've talked about the idea of building relationships, being the most important
thing.
Not just the relationship between your students and Christ,
but your relationships between you and your students.
That there needs to be that sense of trust built.
We've also talked about the idea of really just fostering a community
where questions and doubt are welcomed.
We've talked about this idea of worldviews and what this looks like and
being patient with your students in determining what their worldview
actually is and to not be surprised if somehow their worldview doesn't quite
line up with what you thought.
And we've even talked about sort of how to get rid of that barrier wall
between what you're talking about in terms of objective truth and their
view of truth in a very postmodern, relative to this day,
post-truth kind of world that they're consistently exposed to in school
and in a media and whatnot.
That's a lot.
That's a lot to take in over the course of four weeks.
So now would be a really, really good time if you haven't done so already
to check in with your small group leaders,
check in with your other leaders,
to see how these things are going,
to make sure that the community is starting to coalesce together,
that students feel like they can ask the questions.
Check in with some of your key students who have the pulse of the youth group
to sort of get a feel for where everybody is and are you accomplishing these goals.
It might look to you like you are,
but don't be surprised if there's a little bit of angst and a little bit of struggle.
But don't panic either if it's not happening just yet.
The important thing right now is to keep your hand on the pulse of your group
so that you can navigate it as you go
and you are increasing that level of trust
and increasing the student's ability to ask the tough questions.
You suddenly might fall back into old questions that were asked in different lessons
because now students finally feel like they can ask that particular question
or answer that particular question that we're asking of them.
So just be ready for it,
check in with your small group leaders,
check in with a couple of students to figure out where everything is
and then strategize as to how you might move forward.
But remember when we're talking about worldviews,
the three things you need to keep in mind
is that your students may not have necessarily a biblical worldview
that you think that they have,
but their worldview needs to not be a buffet,
but coherent and consistent.
And don't expect them to change it right away.
Be patient and I think that's probably the most important piece
is be patient with them.
Pray with them.
Continue to walk alongside them to help them understand truth
and how it fits in
and how truth is going to change their reality
and how understanding scripture
and their understanding of truth
is going to actually change their worldview slowly but also profoundly.